le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
pour accompagner les réunionnais même
lorsqu'ils doivent se rendre en
métropole le département possède une
antenne à paris qui coordonne plusieurs
services depuis le mois d'octobre les
locaux proposent un nouvel espace la
boutique et galeries île de la réunion
un site pour promouvoir l'image de l'île
à travers ses produits typiques de
qualité comme le curcuma ou le chocolat
[Musique]
au coeur de paris derrière les façades
haussmanniennes une curiosité exotique a
posé ses bagages un rayon de soleil en
provenance de l'océan indien
[Musique]
c'est ici dans les locaux de la
collectivité et du cnls armes que le
département de la réunion vient d'ouvrir
une boutique galerie une vitrine sur le
savoir-faire et l'authenticité de l'île
mais aussi un petit bout de pays pour
les expatriés nostalgique
au curcuma la réunion nouveau papa il
faut les
goûts jean-marc repart donc avec dans
son sac un concentré de labeur de
passion et de traditions
[Musique]
car c'est à 9000 kilomètres de là dans
les hauts de saint-joseph à la plaine
des grègues que l'histoire du curcuma
puise ses racines alors là on enlève la
t1 dans les modes de curcuma donc on
appelle ça secoue et on va taper ça sur
un caillou pour dégager la terre et
c'est là qu'on va récupérer les doigts
et les merdes de septembre à novembre de
nombreux habitants se consacrent à la
récolte et à la transformation parmi eux
mais mais rivière est devenu une figure
incontournable du safran pays voilà on
va monter à la maison
oh je fais là la transformation du coeur
rue m'a donc
les différentes étapes se font carrément
chez moi
là vous êtes là mon domicile c'est la
partie où on traite que le curcuma comme
l'hapoël etc ont amassé assez grande
j'ai voulu que les opérations un match
où
on l'a bien on a bien séché et la juste
un petit coup de chalumeau ça va brûler
les plus gratuit au fil des ans mémé à
affiner les techniques traditionnelles
son objectif obtenir la meilleure
qualité possible
aujourd'hui le quatre mâts de luxe j'ai
déposé la marque c'est un que tu m'as
qui est fait avec l'intérieur de leurs
actionnaires il est séché dans le noir
qui est très important et il n'y a que
l'eau qui sort donc tout la matière qui
avait protégé parce que beaucoup de
clients le prenne pour au niveau
culinaire mais souvent aussi le prennent
comme anti inflammatoires et aujourd'hui
on parle beaucoup de bienfaits du
chômage donc c'est un curcuma qui se
prépare est dans une bonne condition et
la qualité à lestrem le raffinement de
son produit lui a ouvert les portes de
la boutique parisienne du département
ces produits magasins à paris ça permet
également de faire connaître mon produit
de l'extérieur même que je fais beaucoup
de beaucoup de saveur au métropole parce
que nous sommes assez loin de paris
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de l'île au port
le décor est plus industrielles mais
dans ces containers un produit tout
aussi local le chocolat mascarin
cela permet de mascarin c'est de pouvoir
associer un produit de l'île de la
réunion avec du chocolat pour qu'on
essaie de le faire systématiquement une
des dernières tablettes que nous avons
créé c'est une tablette de noir avec des
citrons et aller chercher des soutiens
galles et un savoir faire d'un demi
siècle que l'on retrouve également sur
les étagères de l'antenne de paris
quelque part c'est l'image c'est l'image
de la réunion c'est dans mon garage ces
chocolats dc oui d'ici c'est aussi une
petite partie de la rive finalement il
présente la main à paris grâce au
département je pense que c'est important
que je souhaite c'est que nous retrouve
non seulement le terroir mais aussi le
savoir-faire donc et savoir-faire île et
artisanale est aussi industriel rome
épices meubles en bois de goyavier c'est
toute l'histoire la culture et
l'authenticité de l'île de la réunion
que l'on retrouve désormais en ile de
france on parle souvent petites îles
dans l'océan indien si t'arrives un
petit produit un petit achard la réunion
un petit carré saucisses la réunion fait
du grand du beau et nous avons dans nos
paysages des vrais sommet et nous avons
dû savoir faire
le réunionnais est ambitieux le chef
d'entreprise se sont alors nous portons
ici cette ambition au coeur de paris
read more easy
[Musique]
la boutique et galeries du département a
pour but de promouvoir l'image et le
savoir faire de l'île au grand public
elle se situe 21 rue du renard dans le
quartier du marais à paris elle est
ouverte du mardi au samedi de 10h30 à
19h pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
vous rapprocher de la boutique en
consultant son site
www.montignac.com
[Musique]
m